hello everyone and welcome to a really
awesome game from the 2008 feeder grand
prix in baku azerbaijan uh it's a game
between them or jabba and magnus carlsen
it comes as a suggestion from an
excellent subscriber
isaac kalamish and a lot of you sent me
suggestions via email uh probably due to
my previous video stating that it was a
suggestion from an excellent subscriber
so thank you for that i really enjoyed
that and i'm gonna go through all of
them even though
your suggestion might not come
immediately whenever i have the time or
there's no current tournament
going on i'm gonna go to my email to my
youtube to my twitter and i'm gonna
write in the search bar uh hashtag
suggestion whoever use that
will it will come up so no worries uh if
your game doesn't come up right away but
this game really
really an awesome one as it's a fierce
attacking game and a lot of
a lot of stuff happened so let's check
it out and see uh was it
a successful attacking game or perhaps
not
uh so rejabu has the white pieces at end
he opens with
e4 now let me just check if i have yeah
i think
yeah it's here uh so the jumbo opens
with e4 we have c5 by magnus
knight to f3 d6 and here d4 for
java strikes in the center uh we have c
captus and d for knight captures and the
knight to f6 so nothing out of the
ordinary here
knight to c3 and magnus opts for the
dragon variation of the sicilian with
g6 with bishop to e3 preparing to
counter the dragon with queen d2 f3
g4 h4 h5 and so on so bishop g7
and now f3 strengthening the e4 pawn and
preparing
uh king side expansion yeah we have
knight to c6 by magnus and queen to d2
so this is all
fairly standard dragon stuff we have
castles and the bishop to c4 now
we have bishop to d7 and now bishop back
to d3 nowadays castling is uh
the go-to move but the bishop to b3 also
uh probably fine maybe not on the
absolute uh
highest level but you know for for us
mortals i'm pretty sure it will do
uh so rook to c8 and now h4 rajabov
starts expanding on the king side g4 h5
is coming
so magnus prevents it we have h5 this is
a very important move when defending
against those flank attacks you want to
control that g4 square and as much as
possible like magnus is doing here
we have queen side castles and now
knight to e5
now nothing out of the ordinary here
this is all again very standard stuff
the knight is coming to c4
where you're gonna force white either to
give up the dark square bishop which is
a very strong attacker at some point
white always wants to exchange this
bishop for this uh
well basically dragon bishop and if not
then you're going to have to give up
your light square bishop and the black
will achieve something here
so bishop to g5 and now rook to c5
putting some pressure along the along
the uh fifth rank and it's also a very
useful defending row because at some
point
uh if white feels uh like going
aggressive g4 is coming then
h5 and you kind of want to have that
rook uh well
helping out with the defense along the
fifth rank so
king to b1 always a nice prophylactic
move you almost always have to play this
like if you don't know
uh like exactly what you're doing you
have to play king to b1
uh you're to lose so many games if you
don't play this but you know
don't trust me do not play king to b1
and see what happens i mean it's
it's the absolute truth uh so here uh we
have rook to e8
and rook to e8 you kind of have to
defend this e7 pawn if you try something
like queen a5 which kind of makes sense
you want to bring the other rook to c8
uh you easily run into something like
captures captures in knight d5 now the
bishop is under attack if you move the
bishop then the pawn is weak also the
queens
are getting traded off and the white
will just have a very very pleasant
position here
uh so instead after king to b1 we rook
the e8 by magnus
and now now although you could go for
bishop to h6 right away
taymor goes for g4 and okay what's his
idea here the g4 square like we've said
is defended four times so
what's uh what's with the g4 well it's
um it's upon sacrifice magnus accepts it
and
now h5 so uh giving up some material to
open up lines the knight captures on h5
and now of course uh
rook captures an h5 giving up the
exchange as well
we have g captures on h5 and now queen
to h2 shifting the queen over to the
attack you want to play
uh queen to h2 get rid of the spawn play
rook to h1 and hopefully
try and checkmate the black king uh
there is a game uh or from 2011 that's
three years after this game was played
anizhigiri played it against bosh in
2011
um a netherlands team championship where
he played knight to d5 and he was able
to win that game even though knight
to d5 is not uh considered the greatest
of moves but he was able to
uh to out with him so here queen to h2
like we've said is still not a new move
and now knight to g6 by magnus the
knight will now help out with the
defense on the kings side
uh and here there is one move uh rather
this one was played in 1995 knights the
diva
d5 was played uh but here we have queen
captures an h5 by tamer and
it is now only as of moon 19 that we
have a completely new game
but also a move that was never played
again after this game in 2008 so here
uh you have to be very careful rook to
h1 is coming like we said so magnus goes
for the absolute strongest move and that
is queen to a5 now the queen and the
rook
remember that rook to c5 move where we
said uh the rook might be useful
uh in defending the the fifth rank well
uh the bishop is hanging now and
taymor needs to do something about this
he pushes f4
and this is not a problem because of
course he wants to do this
uh well also f5 is coming so what can
you do here
uh you might think well there's the
obvious knight captures here because
then if
well you capture this then the queen
falls but the f7 pawn is hanging as well
that's the problem so here you're just
getting checkmated king h7 rook to h1
check
and that's it doesn't really matter what
you play knight h5 rook captures will be
checkmate
so instead of this uh after this f4 we
have rook
captures on g5 and this is again the
absolute uh
best idea you have to give back the
material if you ignore this if you try
to go for some sort of an attack try and
go for the c3
c3 knight then f5 just wins the game on
the spot for a job of uh
there's not much you can do here in 95
you're going to play rook to h1
and that's it if rook captures on c3
you're gonna ignore this
queen h7 check king to f8 now bishop h6
and that's it
you cannot capture because if you
capture this is checkmate you can't
not capture because then just queen to
h8 is checkmate the bishop will
spin so you're not going to be able to
capture that so there's really not much
you can play here you could prolong the
game a little bit play some like e6 but
doesn't really matter you're still
getting uh checkmated here or rather
it came here you can just go bishop g5
check uh
either way k8 queen to g8 will will also
be checkmate
so like i said after queen to a5 f4 was
played but now magnus goes for the
absolute strongest rook captures on g5
and now only now uh do we get uh f
captures on g5 and e6 and now
uh e6 is a is a really important move
because queen captures and g6
is uh well the threat here the f pawn is
pinned so
uh you will not be able to capture back
so e6 uh but now tamo just
happily continues sacrificing material
or rather maybe it's not a sacrifice
since uh
uh it can't really uh you're gonna win
the win it back right away but here you
could go for queen capture sng for
them or feeling adventurous he goes for
knights to f5
and okay like we said if this pawn moves
queen captures and g6 is happening but
you don't really have an
option of not capturing the the d6 pawn
uh it's hanging the rook and capture the
knight can capture and i mean it's just
a
very dangerous piece so here magnus
captures queen captures on g6 now
threatening to pick up the
df7 pawn then go rook to h1 that would
be game over
so bishop to east is by magnus the
absolute strongest move
and the now queen to h5 getting the
queen out of the way because now
while the bishop is on e6 you're
actually threatening f captures on g6
so queen to h5 and now now comes the
move that's
really really well interesting uh after
all of this magnus magnus just picks up
a pawn
f captures on e4 he says uh you've got
nothing here i'm gonna grab this pawn
now i have two pass pawns and
if you don't have a winning attack then
i'm just gonna win this game
and the problem is you cannot capture
the pawn if you capture the pawn i mean
the the knight will just hang so there's
that obviously rook captures on e4 is
coming and now black is completely
winning
uh so after uh f captures on e4 we have
rook to f1
now uh again with some very very sneaky
ideas
the problem is if magnus goes for
something like bishop captures here
which makes sense you are i mean up in
material you have two beautiful past
pawns the problem is now
the f7 pawn is hanging and if you do
this then queen captures on g4 you lose
one of them
and now whether you're gonna win this or
not uh
even though uh you you sort of have a
interesting position it's not really
going to do all that much if you go
bishop captures on c3
b captures and queen captures then well
queen captures an e4
and now look at the position rook to h1
queen
h7 a lot of very interesting stuff on
the board and
if anyone is going to win this it's
definitely white
so instead after rook to f1 uh we have
queen e5 again the absolute strongest
move from agnes completely paralyzing
this knight because queen captures on v2
will be checkmate
and uh you're asking what do you want to
do here and now bishop captures is met
with queen capture so the f7 pawn is
nicely protected
uh so instead after queen to e5 we have
rook captures on f7
rajabo really going all out here asking
magnus what do you want to do here and
again you cannot capture because if you
capture it's made in three
queen captures king has to move and now
queen h5 check
and that's it the discord is covered by
the bishop you have to block with the
bishop and then queen captures on h6
will be checkmate so after rook captures
on f7 uh magnus again
uh goes for the uh for the strongest
idea bishop captures on b3
you could also throw in the in between
rook to f8 but it's kind of the same
idea so bishop captures
a capturus on b3 and now
again magnus says this position is now
just winning for me i'm just going to
play
g3 but the g3 is not an easy decision to
make because
you might think why not play just d5 d4
and that's it
but you could run into into trouble i'm
just showing all of these lines to show
you how rich the position is for example
if you try something like d5
and threaten d4 uh rook d7
and black is not winning this game
anymore the problem is if you just
continue pushing your pawns then the
knight can come to d5 and that's it
there's no defense against knight to f6
uh for just to show you just knight f6
check and that's it you don't have
anything if king here this is checkmate
the king cannot go anywhere here uh you
have to give up the queen then you're
just lost and of course if bishop
captures then this is just uh well
uh very nice checkmate along the light
squares so
after a captures on b3 magnus goes for
the absolute uh
strongest idea and that is g3 and now
king to a2 or java
uh sidesteps with the king uh we have
rooked
f8 now again uh the absolute strongest
if you continue with the g2
then you allow uh well some trickery
here for example rook captures on b7
and now again your light squares are
very weak uh you're going to be able to
you know
check the the blacking as much as you
want and there really is no way
uh for black to uh to win this anymore
it's
simply not possible uh you'd have to go
for something like
queen a5 and then let's say knight f4
queen goes back to e5
and not much is happening here if you
give white any move then
just uh this is enough to force a
perpetual
so instead after this king to you to
move like i said rook to f8 absolute
strongest and you also have to be
careful if the queen ever moves
here i mean just captures and you know
queen captures here so this
this does make sense uh rook to f8 and
now finally rajabov has to trade we have
rook captures king captures and
queen to g for now keeping an eye on the
pawn here not allowing the pawn to be
pushed to g2
but now e3 is coming uh we have g6 by
rajabov and now
magnus does something a bit too
premature uh it's a wonderful position
for black you have one pass pawn two
pass pawn
the knight cannot move at all because
this is checkmate but magnus
rushes uh with his next move a bit too
too quickly he should have improved the
position a little bit he played
e2 uh and then now the victory is no
longer possible however it's no longer
possible only if rajabov plays the
absolute strongest idea
so feel free to pause the video and try
to find this absolutely
best idea for a job of while i give you
a couple of seconds
[Music]
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on finding the
only move that
doesn't lose the game and for those of
you who just want to enjoy the show it's
queen to d7 queen to d7 yes
not anywhere else not here not here not
here not here
or or here or you know anywhere uh queen
to d7
and that's it uh if you're wondering why
is this uh
a draw uh well the problem is if you
continue pushing let's say you bring a
queen into a game
it doesn't matter just queen to f7
checkmate so obviously
you can't bring the queen into the game
you have to move the king uh or
play something if you play queen to e7
now you're gonna lose
use the light squares uh because the
pawn covers all of the light squares and
uh
well magnus has pieces on the dark
squares so you're going to use this to
your advantage
and just check all the way uh you know
to repetition along the light square so
here we're going to play queen c8
check queen e8 you're going to go queen
to f5 checking the g8 now queen d5 check
uh you cannot block because the pawn
covers this so king h8 you're gonna go
queen h5 check then you're gonna repeat
queen to d5 check
uh or if you know that it doesn't really
matter
as long as uh you do you do it like this
uh you can always achieve uh some sort
of a checking pattern even queen to h1
check is possible then you can go back
queen back to d5 check
queen f5 check i came to g8 again you're
gonna repeat queen to d5 check and
there's just no way to get out of checks
so this was one way for tamer to uh
achieve this but uh he he didn't do it
after this e2 move he played queen to f3
check
but for those of you who are wondering
why not capture the pawn well obviously
if you capture with the knight then
queen captures his checkmate
uh queen captures is a bit different but
it still loses by force queen captures
knight captures and then just g2
and the threat now being bishop here and
then if knight captures you just bring a
queen into the game so white needs to
stop this but now bishop here
and there is no defense against this
because let's say you bring this and
then you just bring your queen into the
game white will have to trade
and uh of course this is a completely
winning end game for black
so after king to a2 rook the uh sorry uh
wrong position uh after this uh
g uh after this uh e2 move like we said
a queen the f3 check was played by rajab
of
uh but this is not the same as the
queen to d7 move because now uh we have
king to e8
queen to f7 with check and king to d8
now we have pointed g8 to check
king to d7 queen to f7 check and queen
to e7 now
uh blocking and there's not much you can
do here queen f5 check was played
king to d8 now queen to a5 check b6 uh
and now
queen to d5 but it's not a problem
magnus says that
this is completely uh useless he plays
e1 queen check
uh bring uh sorry just a queen and now
uh we have a few checks queen eight
check
king to d7 queen b7 check uh and now of
course uh
king to e8 uh and now after this king
the e8 move
uh it was in this position on move 40
that temura jabber resigned the game
as there is nothing more to be done here
uh you're just uh
well you uh black is up a
queen and there is no way to continue
this i mean you could
throw in a few checks and it's very
interesting you could play something
like this
then queen to c6 check uh queen to d7
queen to a to check you're gonna move
the king
even the knight to d5 check is possible
king is six
f4 check and king of five but at some
point you run out of checks and now
you're just gonna have to resign i mean
you are you are down a queen
uh so yeah after king to e8 uh rachel
resigned and an excellent victory for
for young magnus carlson who uh got
shared first in the tournament uh
let me just check the standings uh sorry
about that
something got messed up with the
standings but yeah here they are
uh so he got shared first uh in the
standings in the baku grand prix there
you have it
these are the standings uh with uh wanku
and uh
uh with eight points out of thirteen so
you can see it was a very strong
tournament and
no one was like an 11 out of 13. so you
know
everyone was able to beat everyone then
you have it with seven and a half uh
grishok and mohammed
with six and a half swiddler and adams
uh with six karak and kamsky and rajabo
with five and a half uh chaparrino and
david navarra
with 5 out of 13. so really definitely a
very very strong tournament
uh so yeah once again that's the game
hope you guys enjoyed it thank you for
such a wonderful suggestion and i'm very
i'm very thrilled that so many of you
decided to send me suggestions via email
it's really awesome you know
really uh i'm only one person i can't
always find the
nicest game so really thank you for that
and if you've enjoyed this clash between
rajabov and carlson i've also i think so
far i've done
three games um uh between them uh so i
will put three links in the description
below
two of them are from the 2013 candidates
tournament that two of them played
together and the one is uh
that very sneaky game where magnus
trolled him with that a4 move so
if you haven't seen that it's also going
to be the the first link in the
description below
uh so yeah and for such a wonderful game
he attacked like a madman you all know
what that means when someone attacks
like a madman really gives us
the joy of watching such a game uh we of
course will award
uh well our job of with the mr barnes
head so there
there you have it the barnes head has
been awarded and you know even though
you
you haven't won you played a brilliant
attacking game and that's
uh well that's what matters in the end
uh so yeah once again hope you guys
enjoyed it
i would like to thank bradford atkin
matthew webb aaron garipur
ks dylan and grant miller for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot to really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the morphe
saga checking up on your wonderful
suggestions
and whatever else happens in the chess
world so thank you all i will see you
soon and have an excellent rest of your
day